welcome to this video playing Scott okay
it's got no name in that Scott this
German card game actually not sure if
he's referring to that with this Italian
flag okay I have a one game history
against the sky of a draw okay we should
reform yep it's a rare rare line that
that you played how do you play that
night a five order your castle first I
always forget that Thank You castle
first yeah this a 4 in this particular
position is one of those lines that you
look at like once in your life and then
nobody plays it ever and and then you
get it if you have forgotten everything
it's not super dangerous variation but
it's not not bad why does of course
following normal normal schemes of
development so it cannot be cannot be
that bad or bad at all I mean let's see
some play on the queenside try to get
this this Bishop traded that is why I
put it out on g5 no one h6 bishop only
seven it's very often the passive p so
trying to get it get it away from the
ball and it off the board to be to
phrase it a little bit more
fittingly yeah what to do takes here
rugby ate something at it's okay for
rugby to maybe a night only five is at
least controlling see form and sometimes
can jump in to be three which she
prevented okay Quincy seven maybe 93
Knight f6 is okay yeah I think I didn't
expect that move I thought this was a
little bit a little bit a little bit
much but yeah it's entirely logical of
course okay yeah just trying to ease my
defense with trades check okay where to
where to put it on 27 or probably can
put the bishop on a true now I already
managed to activate this Bishop great
stuff but wow it's not so easy put a
nice position and this looks a little
bit like I have screwed up
if he goes to H web place c4 I just have
to jettison this pawn there is no way
around that not having him stay on this
diagonal diagonal absolutely not
I don't know what to make of this
shouldn't be too bad right I mean I'm a
taking quite a number of pawns and his
king is weak unless um I'm kind of
getting clobbered here on the King side
somehow what I don't see I should be
okay I was thinking age six is a move
here what what is he threatening
actually and don't see it ninety-seven
not even that is a threat I can take
here right
he wants to go age 6 or I don't I don't
stare out understand dead already don't
h6 I have 96 I think
and this move is an issue anyway so
there is that some trick that I don't
see him I don't know Queen takes jfif is
quite quite an idea now
feels like he rushed things a little bit
there this looks very nice
Queenie five still Queen g5 calloused
Red Queen Sam
but that's really a couple of pawns
how many points I'm one point up yeah
but II for hangs and check and really
see how he defends his weaknesses f
three edges take and night comes to
equal as well okay going up right I
don't want passive defense or passive
play not defending here ready so he is
might be 794 or I can also go to see
form that's okay check hmm didn't really
see that he takes a six as well that was
bad oh why did I know that very bad
technical check
now that was bad as torta de poncy paul
countess to low him probably to win
any ideas some some kind of technical
like 96 and push pawns just chat playing
for the for the quick passer let's say I
go to c4 kingi 5h 398 h2 is not catching
it so let's try that time morning now if
i take c 3 now then he is catching it so
let's do it let's do this check
TC 396 is coming and F 694 so he has he
has defended this yeah I'm just playing
this terribly bad yeah ah it will cause
a completely winning night end game I
gave away c 5 and a 6 Jim very very bad
check game wrong yeah you should never
get out of this check so check so what
should I change this is ok I just as I
just didn't see that that I'm losing
both pawns I mean I even have the better
King here King e5 they all win this is
this is just so stupid sometimes I'm not
sure that I can win here anymore
probably not but it's so easy I can play
here and and just not give away both
this is the problem you shouldn't give
away both pawns if I keep the a pawn
I've got a a pointed edge pawn and this
is going to win every time because they
are so far away that white can never
stop them and guide also there was there
was this move witches check just winning
all the porns yeah there was an
interesting interesting middle game
where I really didn't know how to how to
assess this check here here I felt felt
kind of bad but this is this year's not
leading to anything 93 years much better
after this quite quite clearly in good
shape and can take and he is running out
of ideas while I'm just having the
better structure and h5 is basically
this is basically giving the game away
but I simply didn't take somebody didn't
take this pretty am pretty generous gift
yeah what can you do thanks for watching